good morning everybody and welcome to
the meeting of the development control b
committee now first of all remind you of
some domestic arrangements please ensure
that you maintain social distancing from
all other persons whilst in the chamber
and in the communal areas please ensure
that you wear a face covering us at all
times unless you are sitting down or you
are exempt from doing so and that you
please use the hand sanitizer and wipes
provided
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use please do not
interrupt other speakers or hold
separate conversations while others are
speaking if you are attending the
meeting and speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you will be asked
to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off we will be using
e-voting for this meeting on the modern
gov app
so please could members make sure they
are logged in and ready to use the app
i would like to remind everybody present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except whether confidential
items or exempt items
if you make a representation of the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those sound recordings
for webcasting and all training purposes
the council members of the public and
press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded
if you hear the alarm leave the building
immediately via a fire exit and make
your way to the assembly point ipswich
town football ground
follow the signs directing you to the
fire exits at each end of the floor do
not enter the atrium the ground floor
and walkways if you are in the atrium at
any time of the alarm follow the signs
to the nearest fire exit
use the stairs and not the lifts do not
re-enter the building until you are told
it is safe to do so
so introductions we have ian duprey our
legal advisor
good morning john patman g the area
planning manager
robert carmichael governance officer
and case officers vincent pierce
and alex bregman
and we have ward members today
present at the moment is councillor
otton and councillor flatman sitting up
there at the back
thank you so can we move to the agenda
please apologize for absence and
substitutions
thank you chair we have no apologies or
substitutions this morning
to receive any declarations of pecuniary
and non-pecuniary interest members any
to declare
councillor gould
thank you madam chair
this is in relation to
o2
617
lax field is
a parish within my
uh county council
division
uh and where uh
i'm aware this application has been
discussed at paris meetings but prior to
my knowledge of it coming to this
committee
thank you any further ones can
councillor
um muller please
uh thank you chair perhaps i should
declare i'm vice chair of the stone
market town council planning committee
so this the application third
application stone market would have come
before our committee thank you chair
thank you
any further ones no thank you
declarations of lobbying
well we've certainly been lobbied on the
first one and
i think we had something on the um
second one as well didn't we
yeah
all of us
is that all of us
are we unanimous
thank you getting lots of nods thank you
um declarations of personal site visits
counselor marlon
yeah i wasn't able to get to the felsham
official site visit but i did go there
yesterday and have a look at it thank
you did you go on site
did you have permission to go on site uh
well what i did was drive into the car
park and drive out again
just have a look at the access so yeah
so you had a good drive in and out that
was good thank you
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting held on the 29th of september
are there any points regarding accuracy
of the minutes please
if there are none
so can i have a proposal and the second
mueller's first and councillor castens
caught my eye as well so proposer and
second of please
can we have a vote on that please
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress in the mod.gov app counselor
carson you haven't logged in yet are you
will you be logging in or do you want me
to take your vote verbally
oh brilliant thank you counselor
okay
if you're having difficulty
thank you chair all votes receiving that
as a unanimous vote for
and i'll sign them at an appropriate
moment thank you very much
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme
non-received chair
and um the schedule of applications uh
in the order they appear so we will be
uh hearing the first application so uh
which is dc2102924
land to the rear of the six bells church
road felsham
and so now john paintman g case officer
to introduce this to us please
thank you
so this application is for the erection
of two detached dwellings with
associated parking and landscaping it's
a full application so all the details
are before us in that context
and it is in function
this was the subject of a member site
visit
a week ago
this is an aerial photograph just to
show you where we are and it's the
area under the mesh there
nothing's working
try again
just a wider context we have the green
on the left
to the uh west um we have the these are
in conservation area but you'll see that
in a moment
we have a fairly historical environment
to the the left and to the south of the
site with the church
to the south as well
and we have a more recent housing
development
to the east
google has slightly more up-to-date
photos in terms of aerial so just to put
that into context
i find in mind
so of course the site is essentially
this area
here at the back of the public house
itself the public house
main bulk of it is just there
it also has a rear car park
that members saw while they were on site
so the official red redline plan
this involves not only the site itself
but a slight change to the public house
car park to
allow for
two additional uh at least two
additional parking area spaces uh to
replace the two
likely to be lost obviously with a drive
being put in to get access to the rear
so the expansion of the pub is secured
by your recommendation
seems a little
delayed
um i might not be
i'll see how it goes i'll press it a bit
harder just give it a second if it
carries on
so the constraints plan um the
application site is within the solomon
boundary uh and conservation area
the six bells pub itself is great to
listed and there are other listed
buildings uh nearby those are the orange
buildings as shown on this plan wrong
mouse this one
and to the south is the church which is
great to star listed as well and that's
why it's in the red color
might need batteries
just have i got a point at the direction
of the particulars i'm out of range of
it
if you want to use the right click and
use just oh can i do it with the mouse
can i
right click
oh i see right okay
should i just wait a moment or shall i
continue
continue with the mouse i can't continue
with mouse just well just one no problem
uh
what's my dead so this again is a plan
just to show where the list of buildings
are they're the ones in orange we are in
the conservation area and settlement
boundary and the site
thank you
let's get a bit closer
right start again so we're in the
conservation area these are the list of
buildings they're in yellow and that's
just the site is the area just in here
this is now working so i'm going to hit
this one because it's easier
great
here's the site layout the site layout
the long history of refusals as reported
in your papers
but to get to this proposal
members may remember the last
application for this one which was for
free houses
and there was no issues on access
heritage and principle it was refused on
the basis of being overly cramped and
matters of poor design
this application for two
uh seeks to address that position
and is a resigned revised design on that
basis
updated layout has been provided by the
applicant there's no difference from the
ones you've seen before other than you
will note that the extension to the
neighboring property has now been
included and it's a little clearer
because it's a bit closer
each l dwelling is almost 8.1 meters
high around 5 meters to the eaves
with excluding chimneys um these are
slightly taller than the previous three
uh refused which were all around seven
point nine seven point six and seven
point four
um
with a 0.2 to 0.7 meter difference but
they match these heights of those
previous development reviews development
the height though is not considered out
of context
with the adjacent estate or the public
house and i don't know if it's clear on
this particular
slide
the public house line
which is there
is to indicate the height of the public
house
and on the other side we have the
neighboring property that members saw on
site with the extension i can point out
in photos in a moment and it's relevant
lines obviously that's not the
positioning of these buildings in
context with these houses that's just to
line up those elevations in terms of
comparison of heights
so the large extension of the
neighboring house was noted and could be
clearly seen on site at the members
side visit
so we have landscaping
members will note that some trees in the
center would be removed in order to
allow the driveway to come forward and
we have no objection from the tui
officer on that basis
and we have the designs
of the individual properties
essentially the designs take
cues from the public house itself which
offer flint
work detailing
and on generous plots with garaging to
the sides to avoid being dominant
so this is the public house itself we've
all seen it now
i'll just go through these photos that's
the
well a picture of the green in the in
the in the background and the corner as
you come around to the public house
and that's to complete the corner
that's the entrance to the public house
and car park
and various pictures
and standing within the site so the
extension of the neighboring property
mentioned is the one on the left there
and that's the site within the site
and that is the far
east boundary
and that's the clump of trees some of
which within the center of that would
need to be removed in order to have a
driveway come through
and that's back to the aerial
so obviously one of the discussion
points of this application is the point
of access
this is a the highways plan provided by
suffolk county council's highways the
green area is
the highway land
that is what the highways authority
consider to be within their scope of
control and ownership
this obviously as you can see varies
with width as you go along the road
the visibility of an access is a point
taken from the edge of the carriageway
a carriageway is not the same as highway
land it could include highway verge
footway and various uses in the highway
land so the edge of the carrier
carriageway is a different concept of
what is highway land
however edge of carriageway is not a
defined term
now we rely on drawings standard
drawings provided by suffolk county
council which referred to the edge of
the carriageway but they don't define
what the age carriageway should be
doing a little bit of research
central government for the purposes of
traffic signs uh guidance defines the
edge of carriageway as being defined by
markings
or defined by the curb
neither of those
actually apply in these this case
because there are no markings and there
is no curb
in my normal experience there is a
logical edge of carriageway but i think
in this case that has been a matter of
debate
so
if you take the wall the listed ball
just to the edge of the
highway as the point of reference as the
point you take a visibility from there
would be no visibility available for
this current public house because
essentially 2.4 meters back you'd be
looking to the right and straight
through your current wall that's already
there you wouldn't be able to see past
it
so if you take the grass bank
and continue the line
as the grass bank is an obstacle in the
highway and continue the line around
that might be logical
you still do not achieve the guidance
set by highways
you might gain around about 20 meters of
visibility but as the curve continues
round you'd still be staring at a brick
wall in the way because you wouldn't be
able to get see across
the next choice you have is to consider
how reasonable
do you pull out that would not conflict
with the passing traffic itself
now as the parked car is available on
site in the member site visit
demonstrated the road is actually quite
wide
it is beyond the standard 5.5 metre
standard road that you
highways would now seek in in new
housing estates for example
for the main estate road
so thus there's a fair degree of
allowance to allow a car to pull out
without conflict with passing traffic
and this is the position that the
highways authority have taken in this
case which has resulted in
this drawing
based on those principles
this still doesn't achieve 43 meters in
one direction it only achieves 40 meters
and of course we'd need to cut back the
vegetation that is there a little as
well
um this is the
this is supported by the highways
authority it is a judgment in terms of
whether that is good or not um
but there is no evidence of serious
slight or fatal accidents in the last 22
years which is as far back as records
we've got
we also have this is an existing access
and they all weigh in the balance
on this occasion no harm is identified
by heritage
highways are recommended conditions but
it is noted that the access remains a
point of concern
it is agreed that access visibility to
the west is short by three metres to
meet the current standard guidance of
the highways authority for a 30 mile an
hour road
and highways have specifically
referenced this
as a part of their response and taking
it into account
however they do consider
and this is agreed by planning officers
that with a planning condition to impose
to achieve 40 meters it means it will be
an improvement to the current provision
available and an improvement for the
public house users as well as the two
houses
this is our proposal for two bespoke
dwellings
they use the existing drive to avoid any
heritage concern
this will alter views into the site from
existing gardens but given the distance
and sighting not considered to be
significant in itself to be intrusive to
warrant refusal
we now have got the ecology report sort
as referred to in your papers
and referred to as part of the
recommendation but the recommendation is
to remain the same as a delegated
approval to allow officers to complete
the review of this report and add any
conditions on ecology as necessary
on that basis i conclude
thank you for that john um and
councillor stringer is straight out of
the trap before i ask the question bless
you
sorry
your question to the officer yeah sorry
i didn't mean to steal your thunder
chair
i just wanted to
uh expand on the what i see as a
conflict between page 55 and page 65.
page 65 is where
the
you were telling me that highway is
owned
up until the green area that you have
you shoe shaded on a map yet the edge of
the carriageway for visibility purposes
was the black dotted line
shown on page 65
yet the red line on page 55 doesn't go
as far as the dotted
black line therefore we couldn't enforce
marking the edge of the carriageway as
part of this application
if we did then mark it along the black
dotted line that would allow people
this delineated space to then park in
front of the pub which would then
obliterate the visibility in the other
direction so
i think i'm in a unique position here of
having been on a site visit
yeah yeah
can you actually explain the two
differences
uh because
having driven it and looked at it i'd i
couldn't see where the edge of the
carriage way was
in terms of if i was a visitor to the
pub or whatever you or visited uh coming
out of these new dwellers new dwellings
where is the edge of the carriageway
and and how can it be delineated
so that the most up-to-date highways
plan i got was the one i put on on the
screen um that green area is what the
highways consider to be in their control
um
i don't have an edge a highway that's
pretty much my point there isn't one
it's a blurry line so where you take a
logical point to put a visibility
display is a matter of debate
ultimately
the default here is this pub has been an
operation for i don't know how long
without incident that we are aware of
can i just interrupt there for on on as
your question may develop a little more
but it must be a question am i right in
thinking that there was some debate at
some time about putting line markings
and it was decided not to yeah i think
that that you know i think that's where
we are on that one council stringer the
the previous application for one moment
the lines were um proposed in to
effectively define where the edge of
carriageway could be
um but that was opposed um because it
would potentially have a detrimental
effect on the character of the
conservation area in terms of visual
appearance
so the highways agreed they weren't
necessary and therefore that was removed
from the scheme
so that's the answer to sort of that
question at the moment councillor
stringer unless there's a further
question rather than debate we can bring
it into debate later of course so what
you're telling me is the edge of the
the agreed edge of the carriageway could
be delineated if we could get over the
heritage concern
it wasn't heritage that objected was it
it was a battle of the
local residents objected to the idea of
putting lines on the on the plan
on the road and therefore
uh on the discussion with the highways
authority at the time the highways
didn't feel they were necessary
and therefore we did not pursue that any
further
no correspondence with heritage at that
time was carried out
so can we use that in debate later
councillor stringer thank you any
further questions for the planning
officer
council of war boys and then councillor
custon thank you
spells is a listed building uh i must
confess this question is prompted by
email received which can take copies of
replies from the heritage officer
regarding the setting
not just of chestnut tree
farm i think it is which is referred to
in the document but also
the setting of the six bells
but that that's not
in these documents i've not seen the
email that you were can i interrupt you
on that one those emails that came to us
were actually
from the previous applications and if
you look at the dates of them they have
been superseded by um the heritage
officer has said that any previous
issues had now been overcome if you look
at the documents that have been sent in
our papers and you're referring to the
documents that were sent last night or
yesterday afternoon aren't you
yes yes and what they were heritage
documents for the previous application
and they're dated
um i forget what date they were i did
write them down and brought them with me
but where they are on my papers but they
were dated 2010
at the 2020 sorry the heritage ones and
then there's one from the heritage
officer now in our papers which says
that any previous heritage issues had
been overcome by this
application so i think we need to be
clear on what we're looking at yeah
that's why i was asking the question
yeah i'm sorry thank you and john
wouldn't have got that because we only
got that as lobbying he wouldn't have
got that he certainly didn't get it from
me anyway
thank you does that answer your question
whether you accept the the result it's
up to you to decide but that's what the
answer is
okay thank you counselor
thank you very much um i read in the
paper the the ecology report wasn't
fully completed
um
is that has that been completed now or
um yes i have now received that um we
like i said in my recommendation we are
maintaining our recommendation just so
we can have a final look through it and
if there's any and it gives us also the
ability to add any further conditions on
ecology as necessary but having read for
it there's nothing of concern it is just
a matter of we're still saying please
delegate approval to us just to add
conditions as necessary on that basis
um in the recommendation it talks about
the details of street and external
lighting
is that
[Music]
affected by the recent motion that the
council passed concerning
lighting which is more
sensitive to
wildlife
no i've always tried to stop lighting
wherever possible for the last several
years um so it's actually my preference
to avoid uh street lighting in this
context you're in the middle of the
conservation area uh you're in the
middle of back of all those houses so
to put excessive lighting there would be
detrimental to amenity more than
anything else i would suggest uh they're
fairly used to a dark environment at the
back there at the back of their their
houses so what that is why we we sought
to reduce potential lighting from from
any external lighting
thank you
so if we've now finished with questions
of the officer we now have a public
speaker
so we invite the parish council hayley
nunn and you have three minutes if you'd
like to come forward and speak please or
no you're there and speak
yeah that's you press the button if you
would
the proposed development is at the very
core of the village centre and the
article 4 conservation area this area of
the village has designated heritage
assets in the six bells saint peter's
church and the two neighbouring
properties as well as some
non-designated assets most of which
would overlook the proposed development
the os map of 1885 shows the space
jointly bounded with the six bells and
three ways house little has changed here
since the publication of this map and
many of the views remain the same and
should be preserved
lp 21 of the submitted new joint local
plan is clear in demonstrating the
important contribution heritage assets
make to the character and appearance of
an area this historic triangle
reinforces a sense of local identity and
this application with even taller
buildings proposed does nothing to
negate our concerns your policy refers
to 7 000 listed buildings and 60
conservation areas and its intention to
preserve these is clear felsham should
not be the exception lp 19 refers to the
importance of the relationship between
landscape and the historic environment
detailing that the character of the
landscape is influenced by its historic
environment as well as traditional
villages and that the landscape can be
important to the setting of a historic
asset this is absolutely true of fashion
six bells and some peter's church
lp 13 of your plan focuses on
safeguarding the economy the hospitality
industry has more than ever needed
outside space the six bells has both
historically and recently utilized the
meadow for functions and this land is
even more important now removing this
facility from the six bells by building
will undoubtedly impose a negative
effect on its trade and ability to
maximize its potential
lp 13 directly refers to protecting the
operation of existing businesses and
only approving where there is no amenity
conflict arising from the development in
this case there is a direct conflict
because of the loss of the land but also
the sharing of construction access with
trade access therefore once again this
application directly conflicts with your
own planning policy
your plan talks of delivering
appropriate housing in this case we do
not consider this housing appropriate
your joint local plan is there for a
reason to form the basis for considering
applications your plan focuses on
sustaining economic growth including
sectors such as hospitality which now
more than ever need support there is no
ambiguity in your joint local plan its
intentions are clear to enhance and at
the very least sustain economies
maintain or enhance the well-being of
communities whilst preserving the
heritage and the environment
this application for the land at the six
bells is in direct conflict with your
very own plan and for this reason i
implore you to stand by your own policy
documentation and help felsham enhance
our precious historic assets our rural
economy and preserve the well-being of
our beloved community
do we have any questions for the parish
council
lady no i just have a question um
i know you haven't alluded to it
specifically but on page 35 you've sent
us some photographs of some sheep
when was that taken please because when
we went on the site visit was clearly
very overgrown and hadn't been used for
some considerable time the sheep wasn't
this year this year was the family day
which was the band etc
um the sheep racing was
too
i think it was 2013
2014. oh some time ago the the sheep
racing was yeah more recently it's bands
yes and um the the site um
was quite overgrown i climbed over tires
and all sorts of things going in there
um when was that last used
people climb but was that to the right
where it's a little clearer
um
no because i think the children played
in the other bit
i didn't actually go i must confess okay
thank you thank you very much
thank you
no further questions no thank you if you
yeah just switch that off
so um we now have the objector nicholas
penny eye
um if you would come to your position
please three minutes thank you
thank you
as stated at the last committee and in
the email sent to you my freedom of
information requested weber council
found the heritage report and emails
between planning and highways which were
never submitted onto the planning portal
disclosed at the last planning committee
meeting
you the committee members were misled in
the previous application when the
heritage report with numerous concerns
was not disclosed and an alternative
heritage report with all the concerns
removed was submitted onto the planning
portal instead
however all the concerns raised in the
missing heritage report are still
relevant and have a significant bearing
on this application and they need to be
raised questioned and addressed by this
committee
you the committee members were also
unaware of the emails sent from planning
putting pressure on highways to support
the use of the pub access for the new
houses and even suggested how highways
could justify the use of the access even
though highways had consistently
maintained that this the numerous emails
that the existing access is considered
substandard due to the lack of
visibility yet 20 minutes later highway
sent an email back to plan in saying
that the access could meet visibilities
how is this possible when there have
been no changes or improvements to the
access
how can we have trust in planning and
highways when documents are not
disclosed to the planning committee for
scrutiny are made public in what is
meant to be an open consultation process
how can you the planning committee
members make a balanced and fair
decision without all the information
when documents are not disclosed that
have a significant bearing on the
application
virus rescue services in their response
refers to the national planning section
112-d
which allows for the efficient delivery
of goods and access by service and
emergency vehicles and the 2010 building
regulations fire safety section b513
vehicle access paragraph 13.4
which says that dead end access routes
require longer than 20 meters require
turning facilities
this cannot be achieved in this
application
and is being totally ignored by planning
and highways
a previous appeal inspectorate is
concerned from 2015
for building one house on the land
adjacent to the pub was refused for a
number of reasons
in particular paragraph seven which
stated that
i'm sorry
which stated that
i consider its development as proposed
which would infill the area of land
between the three waste cottage and the
outbid of the public house would have a
materially a different detrimental
effect on the setting of the adjacent
listed building and the character and
appearance of the area
this still applies even more so in this
application due to the large scale and
the height of the proposed new houses
this happens
please you're on to your three minutes
thank you
sorry this application fails to meet so
many national planning and local
policies as detailed in my email too
which are two minutes to list in my
allocated three minutes
i'm more than happy to answer any
questions you may have
yes i think you've now finished on a
very good point there thank you very
much indeed
john just wants to say something before
we come to questions uh yes john
thank you um just in respect of some of
that information that is most well a lot
of that information refers to previous
applications and not the application
before members and i urge members to
bear that in mind if the gentleman has
any concerns about the professionalism
of officers that includes me
or any other matter in that regard he is
welcome to put forward a complaint to
separately be dealt with by the council
and i should also point out that there
is a currently an appeal running on the
free houses that were refused and if
they have any objections they wish to
maintain for that appeal they do need to
contact the planning inspectorate and
take that further forward just to add
that thank you
and that's an advisory for your good
self so you need to uh to to you know
follow that up should you desire to do
so
right so can you switch your microphone
off please thank you
do we have any questions for the
objector
no thank you very much indeed for your
presentation thank you
we don't seem to have a supporter
and so we now come to the applicant's
agent
and so if you would like to step forward
um jeremy heppel i believe it is no
you're there sorry normally people are
behind the thing and then we ask them to
step forward so i don't know how come
you've sneaked in
all of you welcome so if you'd like to
have a go thank you very much
good morning chairman members and thank
you for inviting me to address you i'm
speaking on behalf of the applicants the
cordage group a family-owned development
company
you will have received via email from
the applicant in the last couple of days
a two-page summary of the application
highlighting the merits of the scheme
and also addressing the issues which
were raised at last week's committee
site visit
namely the suitability of the access and
the height of the proposed houses
dealing with the access arrangements
first
it was observed on the site visit the
traffic speeds are low in the vicinity
of the site
underscoring the good accident safety
record of the existing pub access
furthermore it was noted that visibility
for drivers exiting the site
can be significantly improved by
trimming back vegetation to the west of
the access on land within the ownership
of the pub
thus the development offers a
significant betterment for an already
well used and safe access
it is on this basis that the highway
authority supports the planning
application
attorney is the height of the dwellings
the applicant has prepared a
cross-section of the
proposed houses
relative to maple cottage including its
recently built extension and the six
bells and this is the illustration that
the case officer showed to you
the section illustrates that the eaves
height of the proposed dwellings will be
the same as maple cottage
and that the ridge height of the
dwellings i.e their total height will be
exactly the same as the six bells
thereby clearly establishing that the
proposed dwellings are of an appropriate
scale for the area
to conclude this application overcomes
the concerns raised by committee with
the previous application for three
dwellings which related solely to the
design and layout of the scheme
it should be noted that access was not a
reason for fuse on the previous
application
turning to the recommendation on your
agenda as you've heard the required
ecological surveys have been completed
and found no evidence of bats or
reptiles on the site
there is therefore no impediment to
granting planning permission for the
development as recommended in your
report
finally
i can confirm that in the event the
permission is granted for this
application my clients will withdraw the
current appeal against the refusal of
the three-unit scheme
thank you for allowing me to speak to
you and i can answer any questions you
may have thank you
thank you for that members counselor
stringer thank you yes i have two
questions the uh the cross section
regarding maple cottage it's actually
unfortunate that the extension of maple
cottage is not on our plans on the
aerial views that's that's quite
difficult page 55 for instance the
extension is not on there
which is quite unhelpful
no unfortunately
the
way ordinance survey works is they don't
tend to update things unless they're
specifically required for a particular
reason so any extensions of personal
extensions that come later on included
the
on the powerpoint we have got the
updated if need be
yeah yeah sorry the the uh the cross
section shown
was that taken from the approved plans
or measuring what was actually built
because there is a discrepancy between
the plans approved for the extension of
maple college and what was built what
was built is actually smaller in height
than the approved plans
the
the other question i've got is i see
nothing in here
for air source heat pumps or anything
like that how are these buildings to be
heated
i don't have that information at the
moment i'm afraid that'll be a matter
for
the
building regulation stage but you know
happy to accept the condition if members
have a a preference on how that should
be achieved
yeah yeah
sorry
in how what should be achieved sorry
are you asking about the the heating of
the house
yeah so yeah if members wish then we
will accept a condition to control that
but we can't because if we air source
heat pumps need separate planning
permission
so we cannot that need it's a full
application it would have needed to have
been in there already and in fact our
validation plans ask whether you've
taken that into account
and asked why you've ruled it out which
you just took to say you've ruled it out
so it is ruled out we can't condition it
in because it would need separate
planning permission
well that sort of answers your question
then councillor stringer that at the
moment it doesn't have it in although
the applicant had offered and
you know we can just sort of hear what
you say thank you was was the other
question answered for you i forget what
it was yes
yeah thank you
um anyone else have any questions for
the
agent
um i've got a couple
when we went on site
we were shown that you now demonstrating
a footpath for um
potential
occupiers of said dwellings
coming past the um
i suppose we'll call it stables that
were of years ago
and the parish council
pointed out that the doors open outwards
um had that been taken into account and
also will this
delineated area be able to take a push
chair
the width of it you said it was a meter
it's not terribly wide is it
could you just amplify that please
well as um was explained on the site
visit it's not a raised pavement it's
simply a change in surface material so
you know the width of it is not um going
to restrict if you want to go slightly
off the footpath for example
it is there for guidance and you know
for the guidance of drivers as much as
anything to keep that area clear
um yes i mean the the doors of the the
shed do cross the footpath
they cross the existing pub access
already so there's no change there again
it is simply you know a device to enable
pedestrians to know where to go and for
drivers to to avoid them
right thank you now also obviously
members
and objectors are all keen on on the
access
side of things um and also we went on a
site visit and i know there was a delay
in getting the site visit forward and
everybody was anxious to
to get it forward but you know the way
we work now we have to sort of then come
back to a formal committee whereas
before years ago we'd still have a
formal committee but we'd have it on
that day so we didn't but there was a
length of time and i just wonder why
unfortunately
the site wasn't pegged out a little
better and the fact that you didn't have
a poll to assist with the height
and also the area i think it's slide 17
if you can put up um it does show
um the outside why some effort hadn't
been made to trim back the hedging to
sort of demonstrate what you're trying
to demonstrate to the committee that's
what we like to see is what we see on
site
um well
yeah my apologies if
if we hadn't
prepared the site in a way that was
required but we didn't receive any
requests so
i think we can only respond to requests
and you know on previous
site visits we've undertaken it councils
then you know
we have indicated heights of buildings
with a cherry picker or
a balloon in the air if it's you know
not a windy day
i think when this question was raised
last week um we did point out that you
know if you wanted a reference point
there was a telegraph pole there and
that was 10 meters high so there was a
sort of ready-made reference point if
you needed it um we've now gone away and
done a bit more work and we've now
pointed out to you that actually the six
spells at the front provides the perfect
reference point because it's exactly the
same height as the houses we're
proposing so you know those those
reference points are there for for
members to make that judgment
um in terms of the access and the
vegetation where it's a moot point
whether you want the vegetation removed
in order to see how good the visibility
is or you want the vegetation in place
to see what problem is now so i think we
took the view that you know it was
helpful to members to see there is a
problem now and we can actually resolve
it through this application
um i think that was all right
yes
items of furniture in the way sorry
very quick
point following on from councillor
stringer's question that i
i i was aware i must have been aware of
this when it was introduced and i'd
forgotten but mr pierce's health
reminded me that air source heat pumps
the installation of them is now
permitted development as we've just
checked online
oh so
that's just what we should we should
remind the community oh that's helpful
and also to the applicant who offered a
condition with that but that's the way
planning goes is it develops as it goes
along and and that was a very useful
point from everybody there
so um
john
hang on council string we'll come to
debate shortly if i can just uh i know
there was a comment about maple cottage
and it's rear extension i've just had a
quick check of the approved plans and
there's nothing since
there is fenestration changes to the
extension at the back
in terms of what is on site and what was
approved
those fenestration changes
arguably could be permitted development
depending on when they were done
but ultimately the height
and the eaves height are thereabouts the
same
there seems to be a slight difference in
width but of course without measuring it
specifically i wouldn't be able to say
um but in terms of height and eaves they
seem to match up with the roof that is
there so
from the we're just using it as a
reference point so you shouldn't really
be
i think we need to be careful about that
ultimately uh discretion about the
judgment of that building in contacts
needs to be just judged what we've seen
on site as well
um so as i say
one page attack
yes i think they were the points i
wanted to raise with yourself so
uh we now have counsellor otton if you
would please
thank you very much
thank you chairman
um and thank you members for visiting
the site so i hope you saw just what an
impact
this application will have and despite
highways views the entrance onto church
road
is an accident waiting to happen
i'm pleased that you picked up the point
about the extension in the neighbouring
property not being on the plans
in my calling
i have quoted policies h
b 1 h b 13
h b 2
design and residential amenity
this application now i believe has
dwellings far in excess in the height of
the neighboring cottages and houses
the size and scale are completely out of
proportion with a small
flint and rendered cottages along the
side of the site and the six bells
itself
all of which are included in the
conservation area
and current policy states
should be sympathetic to local character
and history
and chairman i'm very pleased that you
raised the issue about the fact that
there was no indication particularly of
what the height of those new buildings
would be
and i don't believe that the committee
can be confident without full details of
the survey and condition of the land
and without knowing what the depth and
height of any foundations of those new
general dwellings will be
i would question on
in previous wying previous applications
and i know you've mentioned this already
that the heritage officer stated that
proposed works would have the potential
to conflict with the pub which is a
grade two listed building
as is the wall
surrounding the car park and you will
have seen the damage to that listed wall
and therefore we are particularly
concerned about what damage may continue
to those um listed buildings in this
site
you
he also asked for advice
and the member from parish council was
also questioned
the lack of advice from the economic
development point of view
and yet we have had nothing
despite this council's commitment to
supporting local businesses
lp 29 any loss of services and
facilities
will be resisted following
following
change of ownership
of this pub
the pub now does have a new landlord
stroke landlady
who are desperate to make this an
established and viable business
and i do believe that months and months
of development
vehicles
noise
will have a detrimental effect on that
business
we've also talked about the height and
mass and as i've said i do believe that
the existing um will be
i'm sorry ignore that i've already said
that
and once again as you have heard the
community and i continue to be at odds
with the recommendations of highways as
you have seen
there appears to be no definitive line
of what is and is not the highway
boundary and therefore
what is going
to stop anybody
exiting that
site
without having any instruction therefore
i still maintain
that the entrance and exit onto this
site
is a potential accident waiting to
happen
you've also mentioned chairman the um
the proposal for a so-called footpath
alongside
the out buildings and as you said
the doors to those they are obviously
part of the listed building um
open outwards and as you can see
if that happens anybody with a push
chair
in a wheelchair
or a disability scooter would therefore
then be forced to then
step on to what will then be the access
to and from the building site
and the car park
despite trying to prove as i've said
there would be no risk to car users and
pedestrians
i have been told that anybody
even on a horseback needs to pull into
church road in order to see round the
bend of upper green
this is also being shown by users of
mobility vehicles it is impossible to
negotiate
you've been told that there are no
record of accidents and i believe that
is untrue
i have also quoted policy t10 history of
flooding
the planning officer says there is no
record of this but i can assure him that
this has been reported on numerous
occasions
causing vehicles to pull onto the other
side of the road
particularly when the water freezes
this is exactly why councillor passmore
who knows this area personally proposed
the site visit as he's fully aware
of that exactly happens
the successful community shop on church
road has delivery vehicles forcing those
driving from lower green to pull out
into the middle of the road
facing any from the opposite direction
and as you can see this is an active
voluntary
run community shop
and is being well used by members of the
community
you also will have the school bus
parking
along that road
with a potential danger for children
crossing over from meadow close
and there is no footpath on the side of
the road from the pub
you have been
shown and told of the drastic drastic
loss of the open community space
and this council has vowed to protect
community open areas
once again there are still numerous
conditions still to be agreed
including from the ecologist and i
have not seen that report and therefore
as far as i'm concerned i do still have
those concerns particularly on bats and
the indication the potential loss of
trees and hedgerows
what conditions will be imposed on
construction vehicles using such a
limited site
i am concerned about the access for
emergency vehicles
and anybody
and the
refuse lorry
an archaeological investigation still
needs to be done
so i make no apologies for once again
calling in an application for this site
it is obvious from all of the number of
others refused that this is totally
unsuitable for any development
and it is clear that the developers are
trying to computate
to squeeze in some completely unsuitable
permission
onto what is a site that is far too that
has far too many constraints
so i urge the committee to refuse this
application thank you chairman
thank you councillor otton
before i forget because my memory is not
that good these days if i can jump in
with two questions please
um
where does the refuse lorry collect the
refuse for the pub at the moment
you said that it would be a problem for
a refuse lorry to collect refuse
while they park on the road
so they do pick up refuse at the press
yeah but they wouldn't surely i can't
believe that the people in those big
houses are going to want to push them
not debating it's just an answer to the
question
that's the question then chairman that
will the residents of those well no
you're not asking the questions i'm
asking you the question we don't need to
debate councillor and i ask you a
question where the refuse lorry collects
at the moment so it does is the answer
thank you and then my other question to
you you mentioned about an open
community space
does the community pay for this space is
it owned by the parish who owns this
open space
that is part of the land on the access
of the site so it's owned by the current
owners of it's not an open community
space but it has been used as an open
community that's the difference thank
you councillor
anyone else have any questions
councillor muller
um caitlin thank you for your
presentation you mentioned your
presentation that um there has been an
accident on that site
how of when when was the actual accident
and how serious was it because that
seemed to contradict with the
information we have from highways
without having the statistics in front
of me i can't really answer that but it
is something that has i mean
i don't say that they were
um critical accidents but they are
accidents that have been notified and
known by the community
and did these result in people being
taken to hospital as a result of those
accidents as i say chairman i really
don't have those details in front of me
now okay thank you if i have another
second question if i may share um you
mention also the delivery lorry to the
community shop how how many times a week
does that deliver to the shop please
i'm not a volunteer at the community
shop i'm a volunteer at the ralston
community shop
but obviously as of when they need it
but i would imagine they would certainly
need to have one at least two or three
times a week
thank you very much thank you thank you
caselon
any further questions for cancer ocean
no thank you very much very full um
debate well not debate um laying out
your um concerns thank you
so we now open up to debate okay
councillor muller
and thank you to everybody for your
presentations that was really helpful
and the site visit was also very helpful
as well
i must admit we have to consider the
application that is before us and
highways have actually said in 22 years
as reported by the area planning manager
that they have got no reports of
accidents although i accept what
council often has said
i too had concerns about the entrance
exit to that particular site
however
cars must have been going in and out of
that site for 60 70 years to the pub
and therefore
based on the information we have from
highways
i accept
yes the visibility if you're wanting to
come over that site is restricted
but as far as we've been advised there
has been no serious accidents in that
particular
time
i accept the heritage issues but again i
reiterate we can only discuss what we
have been told in this particular
application
i would like to sort of point out a
couple of points i raised from the mppf
the national policy planning framework
paragraph 79 to promote sustainable
development in rural areas housing
should be located where it will enhance
or maintain the vitality of rural
communities
in my opinion i believe an extra couple
of houses would obviously help support
the local shop and the local community i
also noticed there was a garage in the
village as well as the shop and the pub
on paragraph
126 of the mppf
achieving well-designed places and i
must admit the plans for the two houses
in my own personal opinion i think they
are of high quality they're beautiful
and sustainable buildings and they look
very similar to the front of the actual
six bells
hub
so at this moment in time
i'm sitting on the fence a bit when i'll
be interested to hear what other members
have to say
before i decide whether to vote for or
against this application thank you check
thank you councillor muller who else
would like to speak councillor stringer
thank you yeah thank you chair uh still
slightly mulling this around but
i
i think the highway thing is in a way a
red herring but also not
because
it isn't because
the correspondence from the county
council when pushed and we realize that
the county council highways officers
it's a very high bar that they have to
reach to the point they they object we
realize they have to demonstrate severe
harm okay
but the point from where they're taking
all of their measurements the agreed
point
is is a point in that road that no
sensible driver would believe was there
that's why i asked about the delineation
to actually get the safe
approaching the safe visibilities play
you have to be so far out in what we
know we've got a plan is the highway
that it would be unreasonable for a
driver to assume that's where it was
uh i i deliberately drove into that
driveway turned around and drove out
again i would not have thought
that the edge of the highway was where
the edge of the highway for our plans
were
the response from the highways
department is is is based on a road
being 5.5 meters the entire
width a driver cannot measure that in
their brain when they pull out of that
driveway when they pull out that
driveway
they assume the tarmac is where the
highway is so they assume they're
already in the highway and they should
oh should i stop here well i can't see
out because there's a wall in the way so
i creep out
and where am i there's this if there if
there was a delineation that would
certainly help but it's not there and
it's not part of this application
the the other bit that i take from this
and i get the point about the high
quality of the design using clint panels
in in in the proposed houses i get it it
looks very good but all of our heritage
advice uh over the years says if you've
got a heritage which is the pub
that you you you don't distract you
don't detract from it by copying it
next door to it you don't do that
because what you do is dilute that asset
in terms of its visual appearance
the the other bit and i take the point
that
i believe these these proposed 20s are
quite dominant
with their height uh they're certainly
not subordinate to what's around them uh
and
actually the sighting of them is also
something that i have problem with plot
two don't have a problem with the
sighting of plot one is actually very
poorly cited for the residential meaning
of those that are going to live in there
anyone using the patio that comes off
that dining room or living room is
directly overlooked by the extension at
maple cottage
and those windows in in maple cottage
are quite large and they're very high in
the air so anyone using local cottage
are directly looking over the the
residential amenity of those people
who've got one that's poor design
so frankly on balance at the moment i
wouldn't be supporting this but i'm
happy to hear other members in debate
thank you
thank you councillor stringer who else
would like to speak counselor cashton
thank
thank you very much madam chairman yeah
i'm having a hard time with this
application
there's some there's certain aspects of
it that i'm not particularly comfortable
with it's whether they're a good enough
reason to um refuse should it go to
appeal
the um
one of the um parts of that is the um
people
passing through a beer garden
um dragging their bins from the house
to the um to the end of the road um
is this is this suitable for
um
every single type of
resident that would live there
um i'm not sure the um
the the
historic asset and the the wall there
the vibrations of having
um lorries delivering
uh materials and plants rumbling through
on on tracks
really worries me but in front of me it
says that's not an issue
unfortunately
that's something that i i have to look
at what's in front of me but it does
really it really worries me that it's
very close to the wall of the pub
it's very close to the um
the actual historic wall which is
falling down in places so vibrations uh
obviously without vibrations as that was
falling down
um
very concerning um counselor stringer
said about the um overlooking from the
extension and
yeah i thought that that extension does
very much overlook the garden of um
i think he said house one
um
there would not be anywhere in that
garden that you could get away so that
someone couldn't see you
from that um window
um the um the access
is i hope that there's a lot of debate
on the access because i don't know where
i am on the access i
you know it does it
going to the site it seemed like that
access um wasn't suitable the measures
in here will actually improve it and
you'll improve that access for a lot of
other vehicles
um
leaving the site
so um
the
it's i want us to talk about that a
little bit more um and um
i think um
i think the loss of land i think it's um
the um
the use of that land whether it's um
used by the pub or not
is only sort of bound by the um
the pubs ambition to use that land
and once that lands gone
it can't it can't possibly use it just
because it was overgrown now
it does worry me that in
mid-suffolk pubs are suffering they're
finding it hard and um
pub
owners
are looking at ways to
you know ways to maximize those sites
but it does worry me about the um
heritage of the pubs and the economic
damage to her so um
i'm not
i haven't got anything that i could
definitely say yes this is a
straightforward refusal but um
i don't feel like it's
the best application that i've seen so
i'll i'll leave it there
thank you very much
thank you for those thoughts councillor
norris
well thank you chair
i also have some problems with this
application um the scale and mass of the
two proposed dwellings
appears to be out of keeping with the
existing dwellings in the vicinity
and the characteristics of feltrum in
general
there has been mention in the papers of
increased water runoff from the site
possibly making worse a flooding problem
which already exists in that area
and i still also have some issues
with the access regarding visibility
display
and also possible
effect on some of the
heritage
matters in that area so
all in all at this stage i do not feel
that i am able to support this
application but i will listen to the
rest of the debate
thank you
councillor gould and councillor boys
thank you
thanks very much uh
man i'm chair um
and um i'm grateful to councillor custom
for making a number of points of
concerns about actually the
the
impact of the construction
might have on the pub and so on i think
those points are well made
i'm also glad that we very glad that we
had the site
visit
because it certainly helped me to
understand
how this development would work and the
crucial questions about access
to
to the site a cancer stringer rightly
reminds us about the very high bar
that
highways
officers
have to reach before
there's a substantive reason to to
object
to it
though i am i'm
looking at paragraph 4.5 on on page 29
which which starts uh
uh
by saying the the majority of third
objections received are based on the
highway on this highway matter if this
were a new access it would be a clear
reason for refusal
however this is an existing one for
commercial interest
and and and so so
the argument for it is that it's already
there uh rather than if we were looking
at it refresh uh there would be um
substantive grounds for
for refusal and i have to say
being on site standing at the entrance
to the pub
and for us to
have to make frequent
group movements off the highway back
into the shelter of the of the
pub car park because of the
traffic coming around particularly
coming around the bend
and i was i was struck by two things
there one was uh the
the volume of traffic and and speed it
was going
uh and the other thing that struck me
was actually how popular the shop is
which is great um and that was producing
a lot of traffic uh which also uh had an
impact on on on i thought on on
visibility and the overall feeling of
safety of that of that area
so for me this does really turn i am
uncomfortable about the highways
access
to
to the site
uh
and there are other matters uh cancer
muller rightly
reminds us that we have to look at what
is before us so questions that cross my
mind on the site when we visited um such
as yes but are these the houses that
that felsham needs are are in the sense
of relevant matters i suppose we have to
look at at uh what we're looking at but
i am
you know for me the absence of accidents
isn't a very
comfortable indicator about uh of safety
you know
because i know in my own uh uh warm
division uh
the people very concerned about near
misses
um
but they aren't necessarily recorded uh
when advising on on applications so
for me that's the issue that that this
turns on more than anything else is
about the safety of the access thank you
thank you councillor councilwool boys
thank you
thank you chair
um
yes i think that was follow from
council of morris and council gold on
points they've made
i think the first
one it's not just about the height of
the buildings it's about the mass or the
bulk of the buildings
in that particular setting which i think
is
a sensitive setting from heritage point
of view the six spells there's a list of
building
on the planet looks quite a a large
substantial building but
looking at it from the road it actually
looks more like three buildings put
together you've got a georgian
bit on the far right which is next to
the drive and then
earlier
bits at the side probably a modern
extension on the end
and that's what makes it interesting
and then to
similarly the
cottages around the round about the road
they're not just simple blocks of
buildings but the buildings have had
additions put to them
and and and this is
like a similar
proposal this this is quite intrusive
putting
two
substantial massive buildings there so i
think the setting
of the six spells is compromised and i
hesitate to disagree with heritage
officer but i i don't feel
uh he could really say that there's
there's no harm done to the setting of
the six bells
um a lot's been said about the access
and i'm grateful for the plans and the
the care that's gone into the
presentation
um
i'm also very grateful to the site visit
standing up at that access uh it's about
a risk assessment
would i feel comfortable driving out of
that access point every morning
um no
why
buses pull upside the
six bells as pedestrians walking down
the road
it's it's not a very easy access
i agree it's been used
for commercial access to the pub but
i think
that's different to using it daily as a
commuter and i think for me there i
think there's a certain risk assessment
that's
um
make prompts me to say that i don't
think the access is suitable or safe
um
finally i think that loss of amenity um
rural villages aren't just about houses
and shops and pubs they're about spaces
too and this is a particularly
attractive
rural
village it has a substantial amount of
space
in the village itself
so
and the occasional access to the land
that has been permitted in the past
you know it's it's a good safe space
for
um community use
um
so i think there would be a loss of
immunity there
just simply losing that empty that open
space um
visually as well as um from the point of
view of people using it
so
i'm not really i'm not
on the surface this looks a very
straightforward application but looking
at it in mod
depth and in particular looking at the
setting of it i don't think i can really
support it
anyone else wish to speak before i have
a speak yeah councilman
yeah thank you chair um
i think this is a difficult application
there's there's lots of different
factors here and i'm
grateful to other members of committee
for sort of highlighting
uh different points um
but i think councillor gould is correct
really in in in sort of focusing in on
the access issue is that the sort of
critical one
um
no i realized having just had a very
brief visit to the site i didn't have
the the benefit
of the sort of full site visit with you
know with with help from officers
explaining things there but
that issue seems to me to stand out
as you pull out of that car park
and look to the right
it doesn't feel safe
and i'm very grateful to to um to john
for his his series of slides with the um
the latest information of the highways
ownership
um
and and that sequence was very helpful
but to my mind it it really kind of
crystallized my concerns about
pulling out of that access onto the road
and it seems to me that we can only
justify
the uh the kind of visibility split by
kind of creating an artificial point
um you know a third of the way across
the the highway
and even then it doesn't quite make the
the 43 meters that we should be having
so
even kind of pushing it to the
to the limits it's not quite as it
should be so that kind of remains my
primary concern um but i'm happy to
listen to the debate and what others
have to say thank you chair
thank you for that well obviously we're
um you know all um
i had a first go at this um
a couple of points i'd like to make i
mean i've been doing this for long
enough um and i really think you need to
focus um if you're all going to refuse
it on what can be defended we've got to
be
mindful that there is already three at
appeal
and
i must admit i'm always unhappy when
there is an appeal in place
and the applicants then put in an
alternative suggestion to it
um because
well it
it's forcing members to say oh well
that's much better you know we've got
two
um
the access
i'm afraid it is already in access and
what you're all saying is basically the
publisher shut down because it's so
dangerous
but clearly um when i hear councillor
warboys an interesting
point would i want to use that on a
daily basis and so on but i do think
there could be improvements there with
the vegetation cutback
the public
use of this land um i don't know who
owns the land exactly they can always
withdraw that that is not a right of the
members of the community to use that
land and this land is clearly being put
up at the moment for development so
the right of use is not public
it is
granted or has been in the past but i
accept
you know the village has had some good
events there
the overlooking aspect
is actually of an already built dwelling
overlooking someone else not the other
way around which is often a point
because when i heard the word
overlooking i looked at the plans and
there are no windows on either side that
would overlook
there
what else um yeah they are large
buildings there are two i think there's
been improvement to the um previous
application and i know we're looking at
this application and i was at the one
for three and i did look it back sad as
i am
and i recalled that uh one of our
councillors here suggested that two
dwellings would be better
so we've got two dwellings so the agent
has listened to that and put that
forward
they are large um
there are a few trees going to be taken
out but i think actually overall they
will be shielded from the overall look
from
various aspects although some people
will overlook it
and i'm minded of a wool pit refusal
that we refused on highways issues
and we fought that hammer and tongs
and we lost it
and it went
to i believe
um the appeal inspector and the appeal
inspector overturned the committee
and that was a really serious
narrowing of a road in the road
um and those of you who know the wool
pit appeal i mean
it was disappointing but the committee
although they refused it they lost down
so whilst i agree with the fact that
there is a danger to the
uh or there would appear to be
uncomfortable
usage of the exit for new dwellings it's
already used the heritage issue we do
have it on page 47
i consider the current proposal because
it's changed since it first came forward
and that's what happens in planning
things change and move along
would not result in any harm and that is
a heritage officer and members are
entitled to take their own opinion
against a professional on that
so the way members are talking at the
moment they're going against all the
professional advice and that is what we
have as a committee the ability to do
but i cannot find in my mind
the objections
that
stack up
so we have been around once um i think
we need to sort of move on i think we
all know what the issues are
um and i'll leave it up to you counselor
muller then cancercast
uh thank you very much chair now i
totally agree with what you say with
this application chair and it is a very
very difficult um application i think
you decide which we've also to come to
that conclusion but i think you're
absolutely right what you say
and
although i do have serious concerns like
my colleagues on this application
i do find it very difficult to come up
with any substantive reasons to refuse
it
and i've spent many hours going through
this trying to look at it could we
refuse it on highway grounds i
personally don't think we would win on
that particular thing therefore
reluctantly chair i am going to move
that we approve that we grant planning
permission on this particular
application thank you
ansel councillor
do i have a second
well i'm quite happy to second it if
nobody else will because i cannot find
the reasons
so on that basis do you wish to speak to
the motion please so councillor caston
you were going to speak
i just
wanted to go back to this um
bin situation that the um
the
the occupants of those houses are gonna
have to um take their bins
um all the way around to the end of the
road can we just have that cleared is
that the case do we know where the bins
are on this particular application yes
there's a bin collection point um just
as you're going in just past the wall
it'll be on the left hand side um
admittedly on pictures as shown
been to the pub
on the other side of the wall within the
highway uh left there so this would
centralize them all i'm guessing in
terms of just beyond no john you can't
guess what do we know
well in terms of the residential
uh proposal there is a bin store
specifically um
can i show it on the plan would it be
easier
i don't know that help oh that might
help
if i got another
closer one
here we go
so
your bin store is is that element there
collection point there
so yes they will need to bring their
bins down this point here to this point
i will say
there is far longer distances in other
schemes um that
i've never caused an issue that we're
aware of but i've been yeah we don't
need today we just need to know the
answer to the question thank you well
you and as you've been on site uh many
of you have you know the distances
involved there but ultimately that that
would have to come through to here and
stop there right that answers cancer
customs question you were carrying on if
you would cancel yeah i just um
it's
it's actually quite a lot further than
that it looks in that and picture i just
um i just think that's
okay yeah you can choose to live in a
house at the end of a drive and you'd
choose to live in those
houses but the um the demographic of the
people in the um villages i
i take the bin out for my um
60
around 60 year old neighbor because she
can't um move it it just seems some
you know
an incredible distance to take a bin but
yeah i do take your point there are
other
sites that um bins need to travel
further but um yeah no i
i'm still don't know where i am on this
um
i
i find it
i find it really um really
close
this is uh this is a really would i want
to defend this in
appeal
i don't know maybe and maybe there's
good enough reasons to um
to um defend us um
i i'm still not i don't want to go to a
vote yet because i'm still not entirely
sure
how i feel about this i think that's a
very
very good worrying point you have there
but this is where it gets quite
difficult that there is already an
appeal running and we don't know the
answer to that so i find that quite
difficult uh council stringer then
councillor gould if i may please thank
you yeah
thank you chair
this
this particular case is one of those
ones for me that's not clear-cut either
way it's one of those ones where you've
got an awful lot of shades of grey
and an awful lot of on the one hand this
and on the other hand that and you yeah
it's a really knife edge one so
but
where we are
in terms of
the site location and what is around it
it actually sets us a bar
to help us with that because we have got
a number of listed buildings around here
that says that they that any development
any development should maintain and
enhance okay we have that for our
businesses as well
uh
for me it drops into
two two distinct three distinct areas
one is that highway i don't think we can
duck the highway issue the fact that
people haven't used it in in
uh objecting in the past et cetera or
new reasons refusal this is actually
quite
an area that's moved a lot highways have
said there's no
history of serious accident
but i can see pictures of here of this
pub not two or three years ago where the
front end of the pub is completely
shingled and there's tables and chairs
and umbrellas out the front
that's in technically what we're now
being told is the highway well hang on a
minute you look at pencil drawings from
the 1890s the front of it almost it
looks like a village green
i mean this doesn't look like highway so
no doubt there wouldn't have been injury
accidents with with cars if it was
people sitting there having a point and
a meal i'd
so this has moved somewhat um but i
still think we're being able to
rely on a plan in terms of the highways
that isn't there in reality
we've been asked to to start from a
place that frankly is not delineated and
not there and therefore not reasonable
for us to use the reasonable position to
use about the sight line is where you
would assume it is
because there's no delineation where
you'd assume it is does not give you
safe visibility
that bit being put to bed we look at the
design of what we have the orientation
of the design in what we have serious
reservations about that plot one that
yeah that they have basically very
little can i ask you not to keep going
over the points that you've already made
earlier can we be married
i'm suggesting
what i'm highlighting are three areas
that that could be used as a reason for
refusal that would bear weight that's
what i'm trying to rely on okay oh yes
no no that's why i'm i'm arguing against
those that are suggesting that we should
approve because there are three distinct
areas that that yeah i would i don't
agree with i don't agree that plot one
is well designed its orientation will
mean that the private area
an amenity there is seriously impeded by
the overlooking from maple cottage
the other more
area that i have problems with is the
bulk and the mass of what we're being
agreed to
agree to today
they are very large buildings
but we are being told they're no higher
than the original pub
well there's one element of the pub roof
that's at this height
but it actually comes to a point
it's it's not a it's not a
a width of roof that's at that height it
reads as a pinnacle not as a linear form
and what we've been asked to agree here
is is a big linear form twice of that
height so i believe that
these two buildings with their bulk and
mass do not respect that listed building
and are not in keeping with their
surroundings so on three distinct points
i believe i cannot support this
application thank you chair thank you
i'll just take one more comment and then
we must go to the vote because we are
now repeating ourselves on many of the
issues councillor gold
on that basis chair i withdraw my
request to speak
yes yeah i'll stop though now
so if members could please go to the
modern.gov app and go to the plus sign
in the top right hand corner of the
agenda that will bring up the subsection
on voting and attendance on that you
will then see the vote highlighted in
blue
the vote that is in progress is the
application dc2102924
be approved as detailed in the office of
recommendation
[Music]
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and that is two votes four and
six again so the motion is lost
stage of the debate or does anybody want
to move on we've lost the vote so we
need an alternative uh suggestion
the motion is lost
councillor stringer
yeah
two options left to us now we either can
uh can agree to defer the application uh
or we can uh the substantive motion to
refuse the application as it stands uh
i
i would i would therefore suggest that
we
uh move that we refuse the application
on on three distinct policy points
uh can i just ask you on what basis you
might offer to defer the um basis the uh
application um bearing in mind there is
an appeal running at the moment was that
at the back of your mind
no i was just outlining the options we
could have and if someone wanted to move
a deferral they're perfectly at liberty
to do that
if they
wished i'm removing a refusal thank you
on on
the three points i made earlier first of
the design of the dwellings their their
mass and scale
is not in keeping with
other buildings in the area
including the public house and then
detract from the public house and it's
setting
yeah this one
that's one
um
the
second one is the
the the
orientation
and and
location of one of the plots
it will lead to poor residential amenity
for the
new owner
due to overlooking from maple cottage
and also i
do think we need to mention the concern
now we've visited and we've had all of
the information on highways that there
is an ambiguity there that
it has not been set out
where the edge of that highway is that
it can achieve the visibility required
because it can't it's not delineated you
can't find it no reasonable person would
would would do that um
yes so your reason needs to be precise
and accurate but ultimately i i get what
you're saying i'm i'm not sympathetic to
the situation here at all
um
ultimately the recommendation i keep
saying ultimately the recommendation
from your highways authority
is that
they support the proposal but they are
also saying that the visibility display
regardless of where you take it
is going to be short to the standards
that they've got so even if we took the
furthest point
that they say is allowable in their in
their opinion and it is a judgment
in their opinion it is still short by
three meters
uh in one direction
is it that that is the issue fails to
achieve so it fails to achieve the
standards set out by the highways
authority so regardless of the fact
they've supported it or not
it's the failure that regardless of
where you take the point it still fails
to
actually achieve the standard visibility
display yeah i just want to be very
clear on that point because i'm thinking
of how the council may defend that later
i think that's very helpful thank you
john that that helps christopher
that's it
you
chair if i read it out again just so
that everyone said also mr patman g or
any other of my legal colleagues need to
make any points regarding it so i have
it down that the design of the dwellings
the mass and the scale is not in keeping
with the buildings in the area and
retracts from the public house and
settings
um that the orientation and location of
plot one i believe is that correct plot
one will lead to poor residential
immunity due to the overlooking from
maple cottage and the highways ground
was failed to achieve the visibility
displays as required by the local
highways authority
is that acceptable to the proposer and
secondary and also am i
i i i remember if we take
sorry
scale and mess
i've got
yeah design some of the dwellings which
was mass and scale is not in keeping
with buildings
yes our members happy that we write them
up and expand upon those points or
because ultimately you obviously want
some policy context within those uh and
words so are you because otherwise we
need five minutes for me to write that
out in full to get that clear now i
don't think we need to give that as a
tacit agreement for you to go away i
think we need to get that clear now
right could you can we suspend the
meeting could you give me five minutes
to write that up into something that
made me wish to approve
yeah okay yeah i think you know i'm
sorry we need it clear now
yep okay
thank you very much for that the
planning officer has now come up um with
uh book of words so if uh john reads it
out and um then we'll go to the vote
thank you
all right forgive me i've not read this
out properly for the first time so
hopefully this makes sense get my teeth
in so the first point is the point
around the access so i'm suggesting
members consider
the proposed development would use an
existing access that is not in accord
with current standards for highway
access and would lead to further
intensification of the access increasing
the risk of accidents occurring
sufficient improvement of the access is
not possible due to inadequate
provision
um
so let me rewind that slightly
sufficient improvement of the access is
not possible to adequately outweigh this
risk given the restrictions of the
listed wall
and so cannot be conditioned this was
therefore contrary to policies t10 h3
and nppf paragraph 111.
second reason would be
the proposed development for two houses
would if approved result in development
outer keeping and contrary to the
character the surrounding existing
properties and conservation area by
reasons of mass scale and appearance and
further distracts from the setting of
the listed public house
the proposal is not considered to
enhance preserve or add to the
significance of the area on this basis
the proposal is considered contrary to
gp1 hb8 h3 of your local plan
cs5 of your core strategy and nppf
including sections 12 design and 16
conservation and enhancing the historic
environment
and the last reason the proposed
development by reasons of orientation
and siting of plot 1 would
if approved result in poor amenity being
enjoyed by the occupiers of that plot
due to overlooking from the existing
dwelling
maple cottage this is poor design and
fails to meet the nppf including section
12 design and paragraph 130f
thank you
thank you chair just to check the
proposal and secondary are happy with
that
thank you so the vote is now in progress
members so the vote reads that
application dc 2102 924 be refused for
the reasons as read out by the area
planning managers just now
if members go to the plus sign in the
top right hand corner of today's agenda
the voting will be shown on the
subsection of voting and attendance and
in the light blue cover
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and that is six votes four and
two again so the motion is carried
thank you very much everybody so we move
on to dc 21026 17 land to the south side
of rambling
and i'll
ask
vincent pierce to introduce the
application if you would please thank
you vincent
thank you chair good morning members
good morning
guests as the chair says we're looking
at a reserved matters application
for 49 dwellings
in the village of maxfield
outline planning permission was granted
december last year
for up to 49 dwellings at that time the
access to the site
was
determined so today we're asking you to
look at appearance scale layout
and landscaping matters
in terms of the conditions that were
attached at outline stage
the one we're looking at today is
condition two the reserve matters
details there may be things that come up
during discussion that we can deal with
under
some of the other conditions that don't
form part of this
reserve matters application
lex field in the northeast
corner of the district
and my presentation is merely to
supplement the content of the report so
there we are lax field
on the edge of the district close to
east suffolk with freshing
stradbroke and whirlingworth straddling
it to the west
lax field does have a neighborhood plan
that is approaching a referendum stage i
don't think a date has yet been
announced
correct me if i am wrong the report
refers to a number of policies within
the neighborhood plan that are relevant
but because we're looking at reserve
matters this morning
i will pick out the elements of that
plan that deals specifically with
matters
relative to reserve matters rather than
principle
top of my list of things that we'll be
looking at is lax 6 housing mix and
you'll notice there
that in the neighborhood plan there's an
emphasis on providing a balanced mix of
two three and four bedroom
units
and also lax 7
the door dwellings should meet ndss
standards
nationally described space standards
we will touch on lax 10
the dark skies policy in the
neighborhood plan although strictly
speaking that will be dealt with outside
of this under a separate condition
just to familiarize ourselves lex field
on the um top right hand corner in a
largely dark part of the
the district you can see framingham
and i to the
northwest
obviously
more urban centers
so naturally attract a lot more
illumination
we also need to look at lax 11 which
sets out the neighborhood plan design
proposals or put policies rather with
all the criteria we'll look at those as
we go through the presentation
so here we have the application site in
the cross hatch on the southwest side of
the village with the benefit of outline
planning permission
the red line
which does match the outline
permission
the site displays and access as i
previously said were agreed at outline
stage so they're not before you this
morning but i have included a slide
just so that you can be assured that
adequate vision visibility is being
provided
the site is on the left middle of the
site we'll have a quick fly
over lax field
so the site is coming into view the l
shape
framingham road is wrapping around it in
that s shape
just to the top left of the corners you
see the primary school
which is now swinging around towards the
bottom of the
photograph and as we pull out you can
see the extent of neighbouring
residential
development
the site you see there at the bottom is
where the car park will be provided for
the school so that will go to suffolk
county council in the first instance and
that was secured under a section 106
agreement that was included with the
outline planning application
i need to draw your attention to
condition two that says the reserved
matters detail shall be generally in
accordance
with the illustrative layout that was
agreed at the outline stage so to some
degree members liked what they saw
previously and that was used as the
benchmark for the reserved matters
so that is the layout that was approved
at outline stage
so the open space is to the bottom of
that plan off of the
image and it is a series of perimeter
blocks of housing
in terms of constraints we need to note
the listed building just to the north
and the fact that footpath 29
touches the site
to the west on the corner on that bend
of framingham road
so that's the outline
layout i've drawn around the edge of it
in red
so you can see the limit of the built
development or the developable area
if we superimpose the current proposal
you can see it fits
inside
that line
generally speaking there's a little bit
more open space to the south and one of
the excess roads state roads just
nibbles a bit into the
the top of the
layout
so let's look at the
car park element first
so that's 18 spaces you access it from
framingham road so you come in
you swing around you're in the car park
we are told that is probably going to be
used for staff parking which will free
up
an existing parking area within the
school
so as well as the
car park area we get an extended area of
footwear
some crossing points
so that pedestrians can come out of the
estate
or from the car park
walk along the new piece of footway and
cross into the school
we already have outside of the school a
40 meter long lay by which is capable of
accommodating approximately seven
seven cars
so that's the lay by shown in the dotted
line outside the school
we have an area of parking within the
school with its own access
that's the view into that parking area
at the school
if we take a quick
journey
westwards along frambling a road to the
school you'll notice there is already
footways on both sides of the road
that continues right the way up
to the
school entrance
so what will happen is the
extended footway will allow for a new
crossing point right outside of the
school that is an uncontrolled crossing
so there are no signals or
what used to be called ballista
beacons
but they weren't required at the time of
the outline and they have not been
required by the highway authority this
time round in terms of that crossing
point
in terms of the framingham road frontage
you see chestnut tree farm at the top
which is the listed building you see
this
deep area of landscaping our own
heritage team are now satisfied that
that provides adequate
buffering
so that the impact on chestnut tree farm
is not
harmful
there is a path that runs through it and
as you can see that connects the
entrance to the estate with
the start of what is footpath 29 that
runs off to the west from that
bend view of the frontage
that is chestnut tree farmhouse sitting
behind its own
dense planting along the road frontage
there is a
connection included and this was
required in outline stage from the
development into mill close that gives
you access to mill road
to the east
all of those dwellings are sufficiently
far enough away from adjoining
properties not to pose any residential
amenity issues and i will come back to
that
insofar as in your report
you'll notice that
we have suggested that plots
6 7 8 and 9
which are
here
on this side
shouldn't have any windows at first
floor that is a
typo
what we are suggesting is there
shouldn't be any new windows installed
within the roof
rather than in the first floor because
there are bedrooms at first floor but
there's sufficient distance to avoid any
um
contradiction with your
policies on
space standards and layout
those are the
the properties on that eastern edge
that's the rear views
and that's the property plot one which
looks to the north
they are not habitable room windows so
we don't think there's an issue there
but we would want to stop other windows
being inserted into that end elevation
at first floor
we get some nice little bit of detailing
in diaper brick work in places it's just
flashed on the screen
that's the view from mill close which is
to the east looking back into the
development site where there will be a
new pedestrian
footpath connection
at the southern end of the site you'll
notice that all the properties are
looking out onto that open space that
space is well surveilled it is also an
area with the attenuation pond
we have a good
distribution of
affordable housing at 35 percent
that does come to 17 units
each of those is below the 15 cluster
that we think is usually the maximum
necessary to avoid
consolidation of
affordable housing so we have got pepper
potting
on this
development
in terms of the mix we do have a good
mix that accords with i would suggest
the neighborhood
plan we have 10 bungalows
which is
a high number in a scheme of 49
dwellings so i think members will be
pleased to see a good proportion of
those
units will be bungalows
and a mix of sizes too
in terms of one bed two bed
that's for the affordable
and for the open market we even have a
four bed bungalow so there's a really
strong mix there's nothing above two
story
within the development so we're not
looking at
three story
or rooms in the in the roof
i've emphasized lax 6 in the
neighborhood plan that says we should be
looking to provide a balanced mix of
two three and four bedroom units which
is what this scheme does
all the properties will meet ndss
so despite what it may say in the report
we've double checked and we've looked at
all the
updated drawings and i can now
assure you that we have full compliance
with ndss
good mix and distribution of the
bungalows the green are open market
bungalows the red are the affordable
bungalows
a good mix of styles
and design
some nice detailing coins a simple porch
dental
cornice under the eaves
flat brick arches you've got sash
windows on this this
version you have a plinths
segmental arch
simple door hoods
again nice detailing
simple
but we would say
of a high quality stone sills window
reveals
a rather nice large
chimney stack
and when you have a corner turning unit
we even have some nice detail looking
out onto the street so we've got the
sort of pentas board there in the gable
a fine chimney
again nice detailing
now the question is can you tell the
difference between the affordable and
the open market
units i think in a comment i read from
the parish council there was a
suggestion that you could easily tell
the difference
i would argue
perhaps you can't because the ones on
the right are the affordable ones on the
left are open market and there is a
close similarity between
house types across this development when
you're looking at the
same sized units
the good news here is that because gas
is unavailable
the developer hopkins homes will be
providing the houses with air source
heat pumps from the start so we're not
looking at retrofitting
of
hydrogen converters or anything else we
are looking at air source heat pumps
from day one
all the affordable housing will meet
building rigs part 4
m2
accessible and adaptable dwellings which
is
another
good
step forward
bit of a spilling mistake there we have
ecological enhancement
storage units
for properties where there isn't a
garage
we will be expecting full electric
vehicle charging provision
and
water bats are being provided we have
now got a landscape and ecology
management plan that we are satisfied
with
um so we'll be recommending that we
ensure by condition that everything in
that is implemented as described
in terms of materials what's being
proposed here in the bricks a fine mix
of
what you might call locally
traditional vernacular
colors and textures
i have a little concern about the
proposed
roof tiles because
it they are in terms of the finland
pentile
the red and the black they are concrete
tiles and members are increasingly
expecting us to secure
an element of clay
for the obvious reason that it it is
better suited to historic
settlements
i would expect us to
if members are mighty to grant
permission to add a condition that says
further details of the roofing material
will be required in order that we can
ensure that the buildings in the most
prominent positions have clay
pentile
roofs
lex field is a very beautiful
village the heart of it the historic
heart of it is what you would
picture as a typically
delightful suffolk village and we do
believe that clay tiles are part of the
prescription for ensuring that new
development
begins to
harmonize with existing
older development
so
in terms of the character
obviously the heart of lax field
has a has that old
suffolk village character but on the
edges
opposite here you can see the character
of home meadow
which is a modern new estate
and on framingham road
typical
60s 70s style
estate development so in in
strict terms there is
very little historic character within
this part of the village
we are suggesting that the house types
and the materials are such within this
proposal
that it probably would represent
an enhancement of character in some ways
but it wouldn't reflect the historic
core
we have brick boundaries in the
locations shown i have a little concern
that in these positions we're not having
brick there's they're expressed as
boarded fencing i think we should ensure
that they match the same quality as the
rest of the estate
so i would be suggesting an additional
condition
so that we can ensure that those
boundaries as shown in blue
are the same quality as the boundaries
in yellow which are brick walls
i noticed the parish had some concerns
about connectivity
so the yellow triangle on the left is
the connection to the existing footpath
29 which you can see on the left of that
slide
the
yellow triangle to the top is the
crossing to the school and the triangle
on the right is the link through to mill
close so i'd argue that the development
is actually well connected to those
parts of the village that you might want
to access
we have
our colleagues at suffolk floods and
water recommending approval of the
details they've looked at all the
updated drainage details
and whilst they are the subject of
separate conditions
i just want to quickly run through how
the drainage will work to give you the
satisfaction that this isn't a problem
that will crop up
after reserved matters have been
approved if indeed that is the decision
of the committee so looking at suds
i'll just darken that a minute we
actually have an estate here where we do
have swales throughout most of the
estate
now you'll be familiar with the fact
that we can now usually secure the
attenuation basin which you see at the
bottom looking a little bit like a
fish but we have a struggle to get
developers to incorporate swales and
that is
very topical at the moment the
government is spending a lot of time
thinking about how we deal with
water
and
advocating swales is high on the agenda
again and we actually have a scheme here
where all of those swales connect to
that attenuation basin
so we are getting much closer to a full
sudden scheme
rather than the hybrid where we have
lots of pipes but they will end up in
the
in the basin
so we're actually keeping a lot more of
the rain water on the site
in terms of fell what will happen is all
of the fowl will drain to the south of
the site and the red dot is the pumping
station that will push it all back up
onto the existing system in framingham
road
so
the authorities are happy with that
system in terms of the surface water
all the surface water drains into the
attenuation pond
and then
it is released
at greenfield rates into adjacent
watercourses
parking the
applicant has worked with us to ensure
that we don't have the dreaded triplex
parking
so i've set out there the range of
options that we have we have a garage
with two side-by-side spaces we have
tandem parking we have visitor parking
in bays
on the estate roads
so we don't have triplex parking on this
this development
i've taken a very small corner of the
the landscaping proposals
this is on the framingham road frontage
with uh chestnut treehouse the listed
building opposite
and you can see a rich mixture of
tree species all designed to encourage
wildlife
under which there is
both grass planting meadow planting and
that goes all the way around the
development but rather than take up lots
of time showing you the entire estate
i've taken this as perhaps the most
prominent part of the development so
we're very pleased with the landscaping
scheme
in terms of the meadow areas
a very rich mixture
principally tussocky grass but with
a rich number of wildflowers growing
through
again that is something that will
encourage wildlife
throughout the whole year
so our recommendation is to approve
the reserve matters that i've quickly
run through but in terms of conditions
as i say we are suggesting that
we would want to look again at the
complete suite of materials to ensure
that we get some clay
traditional clay elements in there
i am suggesting to you that we take one
more look at some of those boundary
details to ensure that they're all of
the same high quality
i've asked that we delete the reference
to no first floor windows in plot 6 7 8
9 and 10 but we do say
no additional rooms in the attic
we will require
um implementation of the landscape and
ecology strategy
as set out in the management plan
we will i suggest ask for an additional
element to the construction management
plan to ensure that we understand
whether or not piling is necessary and
if so how that will be managed
and such conditions as may be required
by highways and archaeology
but in terms of the broad detail you
have before you we are very satisfied
that it achieves a high quality
thank you chair
thank you very much indeed um
members do you have any questions for
vincent at all
councillor stringer thank you just one
how many of the chimneys in the plans
are real and how many are fake
thank you councillor stringer my
understanding and it's a question that
we can ask our
guest from from the applicants some of
those will be real chimneys
but i haven't i can't give you the exact
breakdown but
perhaps you will ask our
guest any further question counseling
melon
yeah thank you chet um
just a very minor question on the
landscaping um i saw mention of a
variety called or a tree called the
calorie pear there which i was intrigued
by and looked it up very quickly
and it's described as a
native of uh china and vietnam
and increasingly regarded as an invasive
species so i'm not quite sure how that
fits with the sort of
planting native uh sort of trees
we could easily substitute that for a
native wild pair
if that would
we can ask the applicant on that one and
i'm sure we're not going to hang our hat
or pair on that one no
but um thank you for the observation
because i wanted to know what a tulip
tree was but i didn't want to show my
ignorance
councillor gould
thanks so much
i just wanted to ask about provision for
visitor
parking please
thank you councillor gould if we can go
to
slide
18
please oh i could do that i suppose
quick can you do it quicker mandy or can
i
okay
so
we have
high
numbers of off-street spaces above the
minimum but we have in here so
visitor parking
these points are all just crossings over
the ditch
in here
there's some visitor parking
in here
i'm just quickly scanning my eye and
some here
here
here
here
here and here
so in a way you can see that what's
happened is we've tried to align the
visitor parking closest to the open
space so that if you wanted
to access that you could park here and
get into the open space perhaps if you
were coming from outside of the
estate
so it looks to me like 2 4 6 8 10 12
13
14 15 16 spaces
so the these are our street spaces
effectively
well they're on street
they are on the street
and the width of the road at that point
at that point it will be
4.8 but it it's in the form of a lay-by
so the parking space is sorry it would
help if i could if i could blow that up
i wonder if we got one
okay
thank you any further questions
councillor norris
thank you
our page 69
paris council comments seems they have
a number of concerns about speeding in
the area
and in the first batch of comments
second line up from the bottom
at the top of the page there 30 mile per
hour area should be extended past the
site
and in the further comments in the
middle of the page is the last comment
request an extension to the 30 mile an
hour speed limit to the west of the site
could uh
the officer clarify exactly what the
speed limits are and where the 30 mile
per hour finishes at press
presumably it's the national speed limit
otherwise
thank you
i couldn't tell you exactly without
looking in more detail where the limit
starts but i do know as i took you
through the slides
along framingham road there was a sign
on the left that said 20 miles an hour
school
area
the county council have not felt it
appropriate to
extend the 30 mile limit
that would be a matter that sits outside
of the reserved matters it wasn't
approved as necessary by them at outline
stage but it could be a matter that
could be taken up with the county
council through the highway service
at any point in the future
but it isn't a matter that's before us
this morning
although i do accept
that the parish council have their
concerns and i imagine well i don't
imagine i know that they're thinking
about school children going to and fro
the school
will excess speeds cause a hazard
the county council is satisfied that
even with the
creation of that new car park the
crossing point there does not represent
a new hazard highway hazard
so just to add to that the 30 mile an
hour sign is on the corner of the road
as
if you want to just bring that plan up
just so we can pinpoint it
so where your yellow triangle is on the
far left there
essentially just before that is effort
so just come down a tiny bit but
effectively
yeah roughly there is 30 mile an hour
point sign
as you come around that bend into
towards the village if you carry on a
bit
vincent
stop there come back a bit essentially
there is a sign that says call school
safety zone 20 is plenty that's where
that sign starts at that point
and there's an equivalent one as we saw
on this side yeah
that's any further questions
nope
thank you very much indeed thank you
julie are you now going to read the
parish council unfortunately the lady
had to leave she did stay as long as she
could
and julie has a statement from the
parish council is that right yes
thank you councillor
so statement from the parish council
first of all i would like to make it
clear that although we objected very
strongly to the original application and
to the principle of the development on
this site we do accept that outline
consent has been granted and that the
development of this scale will happen on
this side
our intention now is not to try and stop
the development but to obtain the best
possible outcomes as a result of it for
both current and future residents of the
parish
our earlier comments are included in the
committee papers prepared for you but
there are several points i would like to
bring to your attention
there are a number of things we would
like to achieve as a result of this
development
firstly we would like to retain the
benefit of the community of the drop
off spaces that featured in the original
layout that the committee members
commented so favorably on during the
original planning committee meeting
we we agree that it was attractive but
it was also an important improvement for
us given the current situation regarding
the drop-off arrangements at the school
which will only be made worse by the new
development
following on from this we believe that
some kind of formal visible crossing is
necessary ideally of course a controlled
crossing we accept that the level of
risk may not be as high as it is in an
urban environment
with
and from the anticipated extension of
the school
much greater traffic volumes but the
increase in traffic
which oh
done that bit sorry still represents an
increased level of risk for our
community that we will believe needs to
be managed sorry should scribbled over
this as well we would formally request
the planning committee members are
invited to attend a site meeting so they
can experience the current situation for
themselves and understand why we are
concerned sue was also knocked off her
bike outside the school
finally we would like to be able to take
on responsibility for the management of
the public open space again for the
benefit of the whole community
examples of projects we are already
developing including the establishment
of community woodland in the parish and
development of a forest school aimed at
preschool and primary aged children this
site might offer potential for this kind
of scheme but we would of course be
happy to agree appropriate management
with mid-suffolk district council then
there's a little bit from a resident who
was going to sit as well but they've
become ill there's only a small
paragraph can i read that chair
there was
there was three minutes supposed to be
for the
yeah oh sorry okay we believe that the
principles of the original layout
presented in the application for outline
planning consent should be maintained in
the final project specifically we
strongly request that the drop-off space
is shown in the original layout and
which counselors thought were was a key
feature and benefit for the parish
should be retained we are concerned that
details of the i think you've gone over
the time now yeah
because there was three minutes for the
um the objective put on there is that an
object yeah
well it was a representation from the
school actually
well
yeah
so yeah
suenos did speak to me just before the
meeting but the the council's governance
arrangements in terms of speaking are in
terms that
a ward member can
um because they have unlimited time
include which whatever they want in
their statement and um and as such they
can include the parish when it comes to
objectives and other speakers the whole
part of public speaking is speaking in
person which is a point that we have
always been predicated upon because it's
also based upon the point of answering
questions as well it's about that
accountability of answering questions so
in terms of the parish response they've
already commented and as as councillor
flatman has read out that is usually
acceptable because it is another
authority and we wouldn't usually allow
objectors
comments to be read out by another
unless the board member so wish to
include that as part of their
representation
and that there's something that they
believe
as they put forward
if you wish to counsellor that's that's
you
you can counsel them
as your discretion council what you want
to include within your representation to
the committee
mr smith i believe you're going to give
three minutes to us as well please
thank you chairman members my name's
chris smith i'm development planner for
hopkins and moore
following the previous grant of outline
planning permission on the site we have
developed and refined the detailed
proposals now before you in consultation
with your officers to produce a
development which we feel will be very
much in keeping with the character and
appearance of the rural village of lax
field
as you will note from the committee
report both your officers and all
statutory consultees and our fully
content that we have simply addressed
all the required technical and
environmental aspects
we're confident the proposals will
provide an attractive new development in
a sustainable location on the edge of
lax field delivering 17 much-needed new
affordable homes together with all the
requested financial contributions
towards other essential infrastructure
via the cylinder section 106 procedures
in summary i hope that you can con
concur with your office's recommendation
and that you are able to support the
the approval of these reserve matters
um i'll just pick up quickly if you like
me too on the points that have been made
so far
in terms of
the chimney issue all the dwellings
where the chimneys are on the side
are
proper real
working chimneys the ones where they're
on the center of a dwelling or the
repair or a terrace are decorative ones
which aren't working
in terms of the car parking that i think
has been raised
originally on the indicative plan for
the outline as well as the
car park that is required to be proposed
by the section 106
there was also an indicative
[Music]
additional parking area supposedly for
people to drop off from the school
as you've heard given the level of car
parking that there is on the site
and also the number of visitor spaces
that are provided on the site in
consultation with both the highway
authority and your offices it was
determined that you know that additional
car parking would be
unnecessary and probably
counter-productive in terms of you know
encouraging sustainable
parent travel to and from the village
school
um i think they were the the main issues
that are raised so say otherwise i'm
happy to answer any other questions that
members may have thank you
thank you for that that was well within
the three minutes um do you want to
raise your question counselor melon
regarding your pantry at all
and any other people want to raise
questions um yeah just um
looking at the landscaping proposals a
couple of
species there which appeared not to be
native ones the the
calorie pear was it and the tulip tree
which i i've looked up in is apparently
a magnolia type
so i wasn't sure whether those were
appropriate to
that location or not
um we're perfectly happy to amend
those particular species if um
they are i'm not a landscape an expert
but um yes we normally propose a a
deciduous mix appropriate to the
location and if it was felt that those
two species weren't appropriate we could
happily change those for for alternative
ones
any other questions for the
applicant
thank you very much indeed thank you
and now we come on to the ward member
councillor flatman if you would please
thank you very much thank you
laxfield is a very
very proactive and inclusive community
and we want to secure the very best
outcomes for
development for all our residents and
generations to come
therefore i would ask the committee to
take the parish council's points one at
a time and think would we want this
addressed if this was a development in
our village would these warrant
conditions would they enhance the lives
of our residents
can we can the developer work with the
parish to secure
a really
low carbon inclusive beautiful and safe
site where people will want to live and
be proud to call their homes
we would also request clarification
about the electric vehicle charging
points that are intended to be located
in the school car park
specifically regarding their maintenance
and associated costs will the school be
expected to be responsible for this
and that was already in that one a site
visit so that's
the other thing i wanted to agree with
was
with
the officer about the tiles
i think um concrete tiles are totally
unacceptable unacceptable in a village
with all the historic buildings that we
do have
and i'd just like to ask again about um
the uh the drop-off space that was one
of the conditions that was put forward
and members went for very um
significantly with the last time
thinking that that was a very this is a
very busy school we take um students
from many many villages around and with
the extra capacity we're going to have
with extra classrooms etcetera we are
going to have it's a very very good
school so you can imagine there's a lot
of people coming to that village and
they park double along that road so
you've got where that lay by is you've
got one line and then they'll come in
and they'll double park then you've got
the school bus coming there to let the
the um high school kids on and the
little ones off but it's absolute
mayhem
so you know those parking places in that
development were one of the key
decisions around when the committee sat
last time
thank you chair
thank you um
i sort of have a question but not quite
sure if you're going to be able to
answer this
do you think that some of the parking
expertise of those
dropping off their children may be
questionable in a highways issue
traffic at that time in the morning and
um again with the zebra crossing or
whatever crossing we have there it does
need to be
um
it needs to be clear just it's not going
to be clear it's just like a little bit
of concrete in the road i think it
could be a different color i don't know
but it just needs to be quite clear
there yeah no we don't need a debate on
it i just wanted to know if the people
who are parking may not be adhering to
the highway code yeah and the 20-mile
limit
where john said it
was i think oh was it was it was
who said about the 20-mile the 20-mile
limit is near enough just at the end of
the listed building it's not that's why
they wanted it
you're entering the debate if you don't
mind that
i just wanted to know the answer john
did you want to say something on some
concrete tiles or something yeah i just
wanted to pick up on a couple of points
there um obviously this is a reserved
matters application uh not the outline
which dealt with a number of issues and
one of the issues it dealt with would in
the 106 agreement was the provision of
the school car park
so the school car park is secured by the
section 106 equipment part of the
outline and it comes with a kind of
schedule of what will happen
ultimately it's secured to
be
supplied if you like
prior to the first market house being
occupied
it does say here that it will be a
matter of it's going to be transferred
to the county council
or
the school
or another body so there's a sequence
effectively if the county doesn't want
it the school has an option if the
school doesn't want it someone else can
there is
two electric uh parking charging points
doesn't say how they are to be
maintained
but the specification of the whole thing
needs to be agreed with the county in
any event to start with so i assume that
would be embodied with regard to that
just turning my attention to the other
points raised
the drop-off arrangement was not secured
so
parking for 17 was secured although i
note it's now 18
on the reserve matters they've increased
it by one space but the drop-off area
was not part of the out it was not
secured as part of the outline was not
secured uh as part of the 106 agreement
and we can't go back on that now
and ultimately and correct me if i'm
wrong vincent
i have nothing on a crossing either that
was secured as part of the outline
no thank you
the management of the open space which
was another point raised says that the
management of the open space should be
transferred to a management company
there is no reason why that management
company couldn't be the parish council
um but that is a choice between the
operator the the landowner operator
whoever and um at that point in time
that would be a private arrangement
does that help
can cycle vince can you put up the
picture that shows the pulling that
there is available at the moment do you
remember we looked at briefing there was
something there so that everybody can
sort of see what
what's available
this is the area that was secured under
the section 106. this is the area that
is being referred to as a drop-off area
within the outline
so you'll notice that in terms of
improving protection for the listed
building by increasing the buffer area
in here
it does mean the loss of those
spaces
but the
drawing you're referring to chair
is
yes
yep
just gotta get to the right point
there we als so that's the space but we
also have a parking area inside the
school that i believe is currently used
by staff
however if the space on the opposite
side of the road the new space is to be
used by staff potentially that frees up
the area inside the school and it seems
to me this might be more of a management
issue between the school and the county
as to who gets to use which parking
areas because you could imagine
that the area to the south of framingham
road the new one could be used by
parents as a drop-off
but in terms of the planning system we
have secured what was required at
outline through the 106
i think there's now an issue that sits
outside of planning between what the
parish want to see
parents want to see the school want to
see and suffolk county council and
that's a metaphor
for others
some in inside this room and others
outside of the room
can you just put that picture of the
picture where the yellow is in
in google earth did we look at it or
something i don't know what we looked at
it when we were in briefing we looked at
a
oh there it is yeah
in the dotted line so it does show an in
incline that people can do that so that
they don't actually have to necessarily
come into the school to park or the new
parking area however the arrangements
will be made there is a facility for it
and it is off the highway
it's off the carriage trying to ask you
to demonstrate thank you thank you for
that um are there any further questions
oh i think we're still on that aren't we
yep no
lovely thank you very much councillor
and everybody so we know open to debate
we'd like to have a go with this one
thank you start me off councillor
stringer thank you yeah uh
i've got very little to whinge about
hooray
no
it's actually a very very well designed
scheme
i have to say
from my perspective a couple of little
niggles which i'm pretty certain we can
iron out
the orientation of most of the dwellings
even though they don't have solar panels
on them we'll we'll be able to do that
in the future if they wish because
they've all got slc pumps vast majority
are facing the right way
look a relatively reasonable design etc
etc i get the point about the uh
drop-off area
is just the
original one that
just looked a bit more user-friendly i
think from the point of view of the
community
not many parents like to commit to drive
into a school to drop off because they
always think of those gates as being
almost sacrosanct or some of them do
anyway uh
equally the the issue about parents
parking i won't go into here because
that's fraught with danger but but we
need to reinforce with parents that
opening a passenger door into the
traffic is a breaking the highway code
whereas the the driver likes to pull up
on the pavement but doesn't mind
exposing the child to that risk i find
that quite remarkable but anyway
we can't find that out here
we could i mean
i don't think we can condition here that
there would be extra parking on that
community area but if of course it was
transferred to the community
that community could work to to do that
unless others see differently i would
however like to condition that we get
rid of those silly fake chimneys they
serve
no other purpose than to detract from
the really nicely designed brickwork
detail that we're putting in there why
would you want to distract from them
with these odd bits of plastic that are
covered in bits of tile uh or bits of
brick
that on on all of the houses anyway i
mean it serves no purpose other than to
distract
and create a problem in the future the
warranties on grp-based chimneys are
half the warranty on the tiles so
actually what you're going to end up
with in the future here is a problem on
those ones when they break down because
they do
uh that won't have in other houses and
stuff so frankly get rid of the fake
ones
if we could get rid of the fake ones i'd
actually be in a position to move
approval on this as per their officer's
recommendation i would like to sort of
flag up possibly as an advisory note
there is a real opportunity with this
landscaping scheme here to do a
brilliant project without school
and if you're going to be introducing
some fruit trees don't worry about
vietnam we've got enough varieties in
suffolk including the earl of stradbroke
apple and all this kind of stuff i don't
know what the relations are like between
laxatives and strandbrook but you know
i'm sure they're they're lovely i think
there's a massive opportunity here to do
a brilliantly sort of co-produced
scheme here uh and involve the children
and stuff but but certainly some locally
based fruit trees along that whether we
can condition that here or not i don't
really know but i think that that's a
golden opportunity uh to do so if we if
we could
you know discourage the the fake
chimneys and and suggest that there's be
some local fruit trees in there i would
certainly be minded to move approval as
per recommendation chair
thank you councillor muller
thank you chair yes i do personally like
this particular layout and i would be
more than happy to second council of the
stringer's approval and he hasn't he
hasn't approved it yet so if you want to
make a first you can okay yeah
i would be happy
if we could
move
removing
a chimney and what have we we haven't
got on to design yet we haven't debated
that whether we were moving it or not
so we haven't
i'm sorry i am correct am i legal that
we haven't yes i'm correct we haven't
had an official approval yet
i tend to agree with what council
stringer says about the false chimneys
and i'll be happy to see the false
chimneys actually removed and if that
can be conditioned i would happily
recommend approval thank you
i think what we're talking about here is
design so i'm not sure we're quite
onto
that
can we remove chimneys um
i would say we could a chimney that is
there only for decorative purposes
we could ensure it's removed from the
scheme would it like need to be a
condition as such and we can do that by
condition right so there's the answer to
the question so um
do we want to go back and give
counsellor stringer the um joy of
um i think we've actually had
yeah two whiffs on it haven't we so we
haven't really had a proper
resolution because it was only if it
could tacit agreement so i need a formal
agreement
thank you
so you can fight it between the two of
you who wants to go i'm happy to move
approval on the basis of conditioning
that we we
do just get rid of the false chimneys
and and if we can have an advisory note
about the landscape condition that we
could
condition local fruit varieties as
opposed to the vietnamese-based ones
would be really really helpful thank you
and so councillor muller i think you're
back to
right does anybody wish to speak to the
motion council of war
in favor of boys stringer's
motion but i i would like to just sort
of support the um
and
uh the um i'm not sure it's an indition
or a point or what about the clay pan
tiles rather than the um
cement based ones they
from the point of view of
uh
they weather much better than the
concrete tiles so future inhabitants
would
benefit from it
see that's why it's a good idea to have
the debate before we jump in with the uh
proposal and secondary because we're now
going to have to have some more
conditions and go back again do we want
to have a little bit more of a debate
before we amend am i entitled to do that
yeah
so can we just have a bit more of a
debate before we start adding bits and
bobs councillor custom
thank you madam chairman um
it'd be nice if they spent the money
they um say not putting chimneys on on
solar panels but i don't think that's
our position to
have that as a condition um
i'd
yeah i agree with what councillors have
said already i'm a little bit concerned
about the um
planting down the um
down the left-hand side of the where the
footpath
so you've you've got the um footpath
going from the um the car park right the
way through to that corner where
chestnut tree farm
and that joins with another
footpath
i think we've got a better um
picture somewhere
yeah right where that left hand
um yellow triangle is
i'm a bit concerned about having a
footpath that comes out there
and um
and joins on to that footpath across
that road around that bend um
i think the planting around there might
be
so
the tree right on the corner which is
the big problem right on the tip of that
yellow triangle is an existing tree so
there's not anything that can be done
about that um
i'll just wait for the um
yeah
that too as part of the outline vision
display there is one that goes around
that corner i should have mentioned that
counselor cast on you
oh okay
but let me just go back to it if i'm
going in the right direction
yeah
so in here there's
visibility displays in here so you're
right the landscaping scheme will have
to
sit behind
those lines
if you're standing there you will be
seen
yeah i think that could maybe
be made a little bit safer um with
maybe there's
there's trees going in there obviously
the main
tree that's a bit of a problem exists
but the trees going in there that could
be maybe kept a little bit clearer so
that people
join coming off that footpath and
joining the other footpath um can be
seen a bit easier and can see um cars
coming the um other way
um the
the other thing about this um
scheme was the um
the drop-off point
that was um
said to be um too much of an impact on
chestnut tree house
there's actually um i think it actually
has less of an impact because there's a
lot more tree planting because of that
drop-off point
i i think this is a good design don't
get me wrong i think this um this is um
quite acceptable how it is but um
it does seem like that frontage
could be better there could be more
trees
in there
the um
the to to have less of an impact but um
also when the drop-off point was there
that does actually
bring down a lot of that impact because
it's quite thickly planted around the
edges i don't know what counsellors
think about that they um
there's quite a quite a lot of the
impact of this site is mitigated by that
those dense trees i know you need you
want to have a footpath free there but
it's just something to think about but
my real concern was that footpath
joining onto the other footpath and um
walkers stepping out onto that corner
thank you for that councillor casten and
vincey wanted to make some sort of
response on that please
sorry because we have a condition
relating to the landscaping detail we
could ensure with
hopkins that corner we did set the trees
back
anyone else wish to comment um before we
can add on bits and bobs
anyone else wish to speak no
so um
are the proposer and the second are
happy with
clay pantiles instead of concrete
so can we can i point out that
okay so let's just be clear on the
recommendation here because we have the
recommendation in your papers
we have the correction we've made
verbally
which included the pan tiles already
because we've put
further details and materials being
required so we don't have to go back on
that one
the only addition
beyond
what is in
if you want to get back to that page
would be useful thank you
is
that a notwithstanding plan submitted
all non-working chimneys to be removed
and the only other note i have so far in
addition to what that says and what's in
your papers is to change a change to
local fruit trees when appropriate as
opposed to non-local fruit trees that
may have been
suggested are we clear
is everybody happy with that
did you get that
chair i do have that but it's not as
well worded as mr paytman g i'm afraid
um
so can we have mr paytman g's wording
then i was gonna
i think the the only way
you'll have to excuse my my rather um
mundane way of putting it is condition
for the removal of fake chimneys is that
that sounds good enough okay and then
i've got the um and an informative note
regarding landscaping
landscaping for the inclusion of local
varieties of fruit trees included in the
mix where appropriate
sounds
okay and wasn't there something about
the um
lighter landscaping by the
by the footpath i think that you'd want
that in wouldn't you uh committee
the uh landscaper needs to take into
account the visibility split in the
event so that's already
that sounds better we can put a note on
that as well when we deal with that
i'll just go through it very quickly so
it's i just added that the landscaping
needs to take into account the visible
visibility on the bend of framingham
road
is that the right
yes okay
if you're happy with that chair then i
will
start
yep
the vote
so the vote is now in progress members
if you could go to the plus sign in the
top right hand corner of the agenda and
go on the subsection of attendance
voting you may need to scroll down but
the vote will show in a light blue color
thank you chair that is all votes
received and that is unanimous vote for
the proposal
yeah we moved swiftly on to the last one
but i think who
up there you are i couldn't see you
being
[Applause]
thank you
right so we move on to the last
one and we've got alex
who is going to present the case for us
please
and that is
remove the existing
[Music]
yes you're presenting it yeah go for it
yeah
thank you chair um good afternoon
members um
yeah this is item 7c on today's agenda
um the application site is mid-suffolk
leisure center on gainsborough road
in stone market and this is a full
application to remove the existing roof
mounted gas-fired air handling unit
heating system
and install a ground mounted electric
powered air source heat pump and air
handling unit on a concrete base to the
rear of the building
here we obviously have an aerial view of
the site
an existing building
the wider view you can obviously see a
large portion of the surrounding area
consists of residential dwellings
we have the
we have the primary school up here just
sharing a border with the rear of the
site as well as the high school
as well
we have the provided redline site plan
again just showing the the car park and
the existing building
again in terms of constraints um
there are no major constraints on the
site um
we do obviously have the listed building
nearby
but informal comments from heritage
essentially said that they have no
comment to make um and therefore
we consider the proposal is not
sufficient to warrant their involvement
so here we have a layout plan obviously
the the red circle indicates the
location of the existing system on top
of the building um it's visible
from some points in the public highway
more so around this area in the car park
and then obviously the green circle
indicates where the the new system will
be uh to the rear of the building
um oh sorry just going back to the last
one um
obviously been to the rear of the
building at the back it's going to be
further away from the residential
dwellings
and we're also going to be less visible
than the existing system i think it's
on this point worth noting as well
the councils of our mental health team
have
um
no objection essentially to the proposal
um in terms of its noise impact um
all they've requested so far is um
the inclusion of a condition requiring
submission of a full noise impact
assessment um this is again just to
provide further assurance and
to make sure that the proposal would not
have any significant impact on
residential amenity
this is more of a technical site plan
but at least we can see
the size of the unit um
again given that given its location it's
not going to be particularly visible
and and again another one where we can
see some of the internal works as well
some of the internal ducts here
again just on another final point um the
prozo would obviously see the existing
fossil fuel
heating system removed and replaced with
a more efficient air source heat pump
this is noted in the design access
statement and and it has also stated
that the proposal would reduce the
carbon impact from the existing system
by greater than 55
um
given all of this information the
officer recommendation is to approve the
application subject to the conditions as
noted in the officers report
thank you very much
thank you very much anybody have any
questions for the officer
i think we're all stunned into silence
with the technical side of things i
think councillor field would have given
us some information
um he's very technical um we don't have
any objectives we don't have anything
from the either of the ward members on
this one
um do you have any questions at all no
no
in that case then can i have a proposal
in a second oh well does it people want
to debate it first sorry i forgot about
that bit
people are shaking their heads no
counsel them
thank you very much chair um no
personally very much in favor of this i
think this is the way forward uh i think
it's really important that we perhaps do
have
a condition regarding a noise impact
assessment as a condition
and apart from that then i would be
happy to you know approve this
so we are adding that in and you are
making the suggestion that you propose
it and you can answer a stringer
absolutely if
if air source heat pumps are now
permitted development
one why is this application here and and
two that's for residential cancer
answering my own question sorry
john you were so quick
i i i would suggest does it actually
need that condition if this item is
permitted development
ultimately yes there's well there is
permitted development but even that
permitted development has criteria and
that criteria does actually have i think
a noise criteria in it
uh in any event but that obviously
applies to residential in this case we
have to deal with a commercial premises
and we have to deal with the application
proposed and we then have the
well no end of control that we may wish
to apply to it in this case given the
location we've we've considered it
appropriate to
have a noise condition and judge that
accordingly
i think also with it being owned by
mid-suffolk district council it makes
sure we've dotted the eyes and crossed
the tees
so did did we get a seconder after that
councillor gould
peter's second
thank you
so i don't think
no i shouldn't say that does anybody
wish to speak to the motion if not we
can go to the vote
not being flippant on it but seriously
if anybody wants to speak no
would you like to open the vote for us
please
just to check chair so the additional
condition is that a
follow additional condition as follows
is a noise assessment condition is that
the correct wording or what because i
didn't quite catch what i don't we don't
need an extra one do we because we've
already got there's only the
recommendations so there's no issues as
a recommendation oh apologies
misunderstandings
as well because
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
with that share it will be as per the
recommendation in the papers yeah it
does actually say submission of full
noise impact assessment so we've got it
there already right okay the vote is now
in progress members
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and that is
a unanimous vote for the proposal thank
you very much indeed and thank you very
much for everybody's input today um did
we have any site inspection requests
which need to be reported to committee
in that case then i formally closed the
meeting thanks very much everybody thank
you